Wisecrack jared here and today we're
talking about a game that was seemingly
made for us.
Perhaps the most overly philosophical
game ever seen a specimen that shows
quite near Automaton.
Near Automaton is a game about three
androids to be as in or not to be.
The moody nine s and the jaded did a too
along the way.
They fight adorable button,
lethal machines and eventually each
other on a futuristic earth where the
line between right and wrong is taking a
vacation and is never coming back.
The world of New York automaton is
crawling with machines named after
philosophers who you must be friend or
be head mostly the latter,
but these wisdom loving death bots
aren't always just throw away
characters.
They often point toward the complex
philosophy at the heart of the game,
at its core near Automata challenges,
players to consider how we make meaning
and truth,
who we are as gamers and why video games
matter.
Welcome with this wisecrack addition on
the philosophy of near Automaton.
This video was made in collaboration
with an awesome channel called extra
credits.
You could catch a link to them and their
video on near Automaton at the end of
this episode and if you're visiting us
from extra credits,
welcome and be sure to subscribe.
Oh,
and watch out major spoilers ahead.
The story takes place on earth more than
9,000
years in the future and follows two
groups of Automaton.
There's androids designed to hold human
consciousness,
but who eventually develop independent
thought and machines were created by the
aliens that invaded earth.
Androids in machines fight a genocidal
proxy war on behalf of their masters.
Though the player mostly controls
android characters.
Choosing sides is not that easy because
by the games halfway point we learned
both humans and aliens have been dead
for Millennia.
Humans were already extinct.
When the aliens attack absent their
creators,
androids and machines are forced to make
meaning for themselves and if possible,
stop seeing each other as enemies.
The fact that both humans and aliens or
dead is not only a central plot twist,
it encapsulates the games existential
philosophy.
In fact,
two B's opening line.
I often think about the God who blessed
us with this cryptic puzzle and wonder
if we'll ever have the chance to kill
him.
Might
as well have been polled right from
Friedrich Porn Stache Nisha who wrote
God is dead.
God remains dead and we have killed him.
Now I know the phrase God is dead gets
thrown around a lot by internet edge
lords,
but what did Nisha actually mean before
Nicha many thinkers constructed reality
in a similar way.
God,
truth and reason,
we're all unfathomable,
unchanging,
and universal concepts which stood above
or outside of humankind,
like supernatural forces animating the
world and moving it toward progress.
In this view,
humans don't make and control meaning
themselves.
It's some unreachable datey or universal
principle which gives human action,
meaning when Nisha declared God dead,
he criticized any system that locates
the source of meaning outside human
lives and popularize the idea of
nihilism is the belief that there is no
great metaphysical forest propelling us
through the world and making our lives
special.
Existence can be beat and there's no
grander meaning to comfort us.
No puppet master to save us.
Now I know we can find each other in a
lot of pop culture,
but no piece of media embodies it quite
like near Automaton.
Androids and machines think they're god,
like masters are literally above them on
the moon and in space,
but those gods are actually dead like
rotting for Millennia,
dead and as we learned from Adam and
eve,
machines killed their alien overlords
because they were static and unchanging,
much like the unchanging day at ease and
morals that nature criticized.
They were saying almost like
humans died after the mainframe holding
their consciousnesses collapses.
Guess nobody made backups.
If the death of God is really about the
death of a grand meaning,
then our dead aliens and humans are only
one element of the games.
Greater message about meaning you kill
some a philosophies,
biggest heroes.
Some characters lose sight of a purpose
in life and the game repeatedly builds
meaning around certain characters or
plots and then kills them off usually by
the player's own hand.
Each time this happens,
the player has to reevaluate where their
new meaning mission and direction is
going to come from.
Even your hobby android organization
eventually dies,
but your highs less like a god and more
like acd government.
They know humanities dead,
but hide it from the other androids
pretty fucked up,
right?
Your hot perfectly exemplifies the
Nietzschean point that even once God,
six feet under society doesn't just
reboot.
Political.
Social and psychological norms are left
over from prior belief systems and we
continue imposing these meanings on one
another and ourselves to be at nine s
spend much of the b play throughs,
reassuring one another.
That machines don't have emotions or
personhood,
they don't have any feelings.
They're just imitating human speech.
Even when all evidence points to the
contrary child,
no need for human masters to promote
this idea.
They do it to each other.
For Nisha,
the best response to a meaningless
universe and a dead God is to create
meaning for ourselves or what he
referred to as self making.
In near Atomico we encounter different
machines named after philosophers
engaged in this kind of self making each
with their own responses to the meaning
or meaninglessness of light.
There are quite a few existentialist
machines to be found.
John Paul as in Sartre,
simone as in Diboll,
Voila.
Pascal as in Pascal and Kierkegaard as
in Kierkegaard.
Each philosopher machine offers us a
glimpse into one way of pursuing
meaning.
Take John Paul the Avatar of John Paul
Sartre in the game.
Jp is basically a dark parody of his
real life self,
just like Sartre,
loathed institutional recognition.
John Paul is kind of an asshole who
ignores,
is devoted followers except for the
pretty ones and eventually soft to the
wilderness to find meaning.
Nobody really misses him,
but before leaving John Paul highlights
the game steams when he throws around
one or two famous Sartre isms like the
existential slogan,
existence precedes essence essentially,
rather than some innate nature
determining who we are before we're
born.
Each individual first exists in the
world and then develops meaning and
purpose.
It's all about radical freedom to become
who we are through our actions and
choices in the game.
We see this everywhere.
As machines transcend their intended
purpose and find new meaning.
Even the pods proved that their nature
comes from existence,
not a predetermined essence as they
developed self consciousness.
In fact,
most of the characters in the game are,
as Sartre,
once suggested,
condemned to be free.
That's right,
condensed because without a higher power
or innate nature,
controlling our actions,
we bear ultimate responsibility for our
decisions even as virality becomes super
ambiguous and that's a tough place to
be.
Just look at machines like this,
sad angles,
boss who like many of the Games
characters is crushed beneath the weight
of figuring out what's right and he
knows he bears full responsibility for
those decisions.
The simone boss named after Simone de
Beauvoir,
a French feminist philosopher,
holds a mirror to another aspect of
meaning making.
DEPA famously suggested one is not born
a woman,
let becomes a woman as the Simone boss
realizes,
one way we create meaning in our lives
is by constructing gender norms like
beauty and femininity.
She literally becomes a woman by
constructing herself and cannibalizing
other machines to approve her beauty.
Both Deborah voir and her demented
avatar teach us to watch out less.
We become monsters in our attempt to
make meaning through gender norms.
Someones existential quest for
connection through beauty is highlighted
in her obsession with John Paul,
which has historical roots since debois
and start.
We're lifelong lovers.
The character pascal packs one of the
biggest Nietzschean punches,
though he's the Avatar of Blaise Pascal,
a mathematician,
philosopher,
and regular renaissance man.
He couldn't be more different than his
real life counterpart.
As the pacifist leader of a machine
village,
Pascal puts a lot of faith and the
ultimate goodness of machines and
Androids,
but the real pascal was a bit of a
downer.
Unlike his idealistic Avatar,
the Real Pascal thought humanity was
prideful,
arrogant,
and unredeemable without God.
Our lives are filled with anxiety and
despair.
In fact,
we have only one redeeming trait.
The greatness of human beings consists
in their ability to know their
wretchedness.
But Game Pascal comes around to the Irl
Pascal's viewpoint and maybe the games
darkest twist.
The peaceful villagers suddenly start
eating each other,
and when,
even after setting aside his pacifism to
defend the children,
they commit suicide anyway,
gained.
Pascal finally understands the
wretchedness of himself in the machine.
When he despairs and asks you to kill
him or delete his memory,
the has to face their own wretchedness
two and make a tough choice.
Some characters in the near universe try
to make meaning through new religions.
Take Christian existentialist Soren
Kierkegaard who makes an ironic
appearance as the worship leader of a
small cult.
Kierkegaard believe that the ultimate
expression of one's freedom is to commit
to certain meaning and make it true by
manifesting it in one's life,
which he calls taking a leap of faith.
Unfortunately,
when some of QCC regards followers take
literal leaps of faith,
it doesn't turn out so well for that.
There are so many other philosophy
bosses we could talk about.
Call Gruen,
Conte ankles,
and mark's Ernst Bloch Hagle,
even the brothers Friedrich in August,
Schlegel Roshi,
Koshi Boko,
she and Sochi are the Japanese
pronunciations of Chinese philosophers,
Lao Tzu,
Confucius Moats,
and Juang.
Quanta was a taoist philosopher who was
in the existentialism way before.
It was cool.
He claimed existence is full of cycles
of light and dark life and death and joy
and sadness.
Only by accepting these cycles including
all the unpleasant stuff.
Can we ever find contentment in life
near Automaton,
taking a cue from junk to bakes.
These cycles right into the game played
as an extension of the games.
Existential themes.
The mechanics emphasize the role of
cycles and repetition in creating
meaning.
Cycles are everywhere.
Androids are caught in the cycle of
life,
in debt,
repeatedly uploading to the mainframe
and getting new bodies to be is stuck in
the cycle of killing dynastic and pod
one 53 it gives a sad spiel about cycles
of life.
Everything is designed to end.
It's all about returning to the
beginning according to Nisha cycles.
Dispel the myth of progress.
Progress only makes sense if you have a
clear aim and if you're cool staying on
a path that someone else laid out for
you,
but nature hates that notion of
progress.
Instead,
we should be critical of claims to
progress that rely on external meaning
or our unquestioned notions of right and
wrong.
The cycles and automaton disrupt this
false idea of progress and meaning not
only within the game universe but also
for the player in Automaton.
There is no clear goal or rather gold
changed throughout the game.
And the whole point is that none of the
characters are on a predetermined path.
Plus there's no straight forward game
progress.
Players literally repeat certain actions
or stories rather than moving linearly
from one event to the next.
The game even ends with the suggestion
that eight to a nine s will be reborn to
fight this battle all over again.
They are perpetually trapped in a never
ending spiral of life and death.
In fact,
relationship between cycles and nature
are most obvious in the games.
Multiple play through structure in
Automaton.
The main play throughs a,
r like chapters carefully sequenced and
building on one another,
often repeating parts of the same plot,
but through the eyes,
knowledge and powers of different
characters.
And sometimes moving onto the next plot
stage,
you must complete a through d to get to
the main ending e with the credits which
we'll talk about in a moment.
Uh,
Tamatoa uses this structure to strip
meaning from the players themselves and
to put the idea of game progress
engaging players in their own nihilist
quest instead of the difference between
the first and second play throughs where
you play as to be.
And then nine s in parallel stories in
the first play as to be you learn the
aliens are dead and the machines we've
been killing are actually sentience and
emotional.
Of course they could have just told us
this straight out,
but instead they make us relive every
thing we did to those poor bastards and
now we feel terrible about it.
The real importance of the first run is
to set up meaning yours,
who you are and why you're fighting the
bad guys and then snatch it from us.
The point is really driven home by the
beginning of the second play through
where you played from the perspective of
a machine red shirt.
This opening seems designed to trigger
the players compassion and rob us of the
meaning we use to make sense of our
entire first quest.
Instead of creating a grand narrative to
explain away pain and loss or instead of
just giving up meat you suggest we say
yes to life.
Yes.
Saying is an attitude oriented toward
the future that affirms everything from
the past without trying to change it.
Imagine you had to live the same life
over and over and what Nisha calls
eternal recurrence.
This would be super crappy if you
thought life was about avoiding pain and
suffering,
but yes,
saying embraces suffering and the
lessons if brings us without glorifying
them.
The game's final Nietzsche and middle
finger to progress and ultimate meaning
comes in ending eat here.
Players literally have to kill their
gods and make a difficult choice between
progress,
which lets them save all their data and
advancement in the game and yes,
saying which entails accepting their
mistakes and be willing to start over as
the credits roll and you battled the
names of the games,
designers and creators which are somehow
shooting that you messages from other
players around the world encourage you
until you're finally joined by their
avatars who sacrifice themselves for
your success.
And I don't use sacrifice lightly.
As you discover at the end when you're
asked to do the same,
all those avatars are there because in
some other time in place,
maybe before you even started playing
other players finish the game and chose
to delete their data and game saves for
the ability to eventually help you a
total stranger.
Complete the game.
Here we're asked what makes gaming
meaningful?
Do we believe in the myth of progress
that what makes them meaningful is
completing them,
saving our data and having achieved
something once and for all or are we yes
sayers willing to start over from the
beginning and make the same choices and
maybe even the same mistakes all over
again?
Are we individual automaton will only
fight for ourselves or is gaming about
the lessons we learn and engaging a
community?
Does one player deserve the sacrifice
made by others and should we sacrifice
ourselves for people who we don't know
or might not even like what makes gaming
meaningful is truly up to the player.
If you affirm progress,
nothing happened.
But if you say to suffering and loss
instead all your saves in play get
deleted and you return to the beginning
to do it all again or maybe you'll do it
differently.
A future you must take for yourself.
See cycles as a game near Automaton
itself embraces suffering both of its
characters and its players,
but only in order to tell a powerful
philosophical story as only an
interactive game could does it pan out
like they hoped?
Is the game worth all the fields that
elicits in an attempt to make its point
about meaning?
Well that's up to you,
but if you're one of the yes heirs who
sacrifice made my journey possible,
you should know it means something to me
and part of the reason it means
something to me is because this ending
is a rare example of game developers
baking empathy into the game play well.
Video Games are on the surface all about
saving the world and helping people.
Most of them lack core components of
what makes acts truly empathetic.
To learn more about how near Automaton
breaks the mold.
You'll have to check out our
collaborators over at extra credits who
are broken down the ending in a whole
new light.
Be sure to tell him that wise crack sent
you.
As always,
be sure to subscribe and ring that bell
catch on next time.
Peace.